welcome sir yes sir yes sir Jersey's
finest is here what's going on how you
doing bro [__] I'm I'm good I'm chilling
uh couple of weeks away from the fight
um I'm ready to put on the show yeah I
was going to say man cuz like you've had
fights fall through obviously this fight
is November 16th right yeah this fight
is November 16th y Edwin De Santos yep
um first of all uh I'm curious like you
feeling good cuz I know like training
heading into the fight we always you
know watch uh I always watch like when
Showtime would have the you know the the
pay-per-views and you'd be able to watch
the behind the scenes of the fight so I
know that it's it's different now you
can't really get to see everything but
um yeah I I feel great I'm uh fine uh
honestly I think this the best I've been
feeling um getting ready for a fight so
uh I I'm I'm ready how intense is like
the sparring sessions for you
like prior to the fight like do you ramp
up or do you like kind of chill out a
little bit to kind of preserve what you
know I I'm I'm so competitive like I'll
be having like issues so like in sparing
I'm more so like the person I like to go
a lot of rounds um you could throw two
three right people in the ring with me I
I want to keep going but um my coaches
kind of got to like pull me back and are
you so competitive that if someone Nails
you in sparring you want to like get get
get your get back hell yeah if somebody
land a good shot I tell him like good
shot we got to run it back though yeah
I'm not getting out the ring until I get
mine so we got to run it back uh we got
to do another round um I'll make
somebody stay in there for rounds and
rounds until they say I'm done yo for me
uh being somebody who is a fat [__] uh
respectfully of course to all the fat
[__] out there I always I always am
curious cuz you guys are so good at
dropping weight you guys have figured
out weight loss in a way that most obese
men in the world have not figured out
all right how do you drop like what
first of all cuz I've seen guys drop
like uh like like wild amounts of weight
pretty quickly like what is the key if
you need to make weight and maybe you
you've been [__] up the wrong food
the last week or so how do you drop
weight so fast as a boxer I think that
um it all got to do with discipline I
think discipline is like the main thing
um I mean that's obvious but that would
be you know that's drinking water
drinking water drinking water is like a
huge thing when you want to cut weight
on do you go into like a sauna and just
sweat it out nah I don't do the sauna
but people do that do that there people
that do the sauna but me I I don't
believe in a son I think that like I I
don't like it I don't like the way it
make me feel after I be feeling like
kind of drink but I drink water um and
work out work out you got to put an
extra layer of clothes on too that was
not the easy answer we were hoping for
drink water and work out everybody yeah
but you got to drink a lot of water it's
not just drink uh two glasses no you got
to drink like see I got this gallon
thing right here yeah you stay you're
staying with the water you drink a
gallon a day or more I drink over a
gallon a day wow yeah that's a lot of
water you must have to piss a lot oo
definitely do I'll be waking up in the
middle of night um having them P to is
it true like obviously your fight's a
couple of weeks away are you
withstanding from busted nuts at this
Point yes you're not beating cheeks nah
hell no for sure how how far out do you
like cut off the the the you know the
the the Intercourse I think I'm like a
four we type person wow good for you man
I don't know how like certain people be
saying like I've done it before yeah
eight weeks eight weeks they do eight
weeks strong um shout out to them them
people they tough and do you like feel
the difference cuz you I have heard like
you know like it's like an energy thing
like yeah I feel I feel a difference I I
feel like when I bust I feel like it
make me a little lazy like I'll be in
the ring lazy smart man yeah but when I
like hold it it's like I'm not as lazy
I'm feeling good and can do what I want
I got to get your thoughts uh there was
a big fight that happened this past
weekend um what are your thoughts on the
uh the fury uh fight oh my God man did
he steal that one man I don't know what
I was watching I you watched it yeah I
seen some of it cuz I was sparring at
the same time got so then I got done and
I watched like the last four rounds but
I want to say I don't know I don't know
what I was watching like I don't know
what Tyson fery was doing it didn't make
sense to me it didn't look like Tyson
Fury in the ring like it didn't but he
still won but cuz it was a was it a draw
it was a draw right but no it was he won
he won he end okay okay but it didn't
look like him like I I watched plenty of
Tyson fery fights and uh usually he's
punching it didn't look like he was even
throwing punches he was doing a lot of
hugging he wasn't punching it didn't
make sense to me like it it didn't he
didn't look like the same person to me I
wonder like cuz you always see like I
haven't seen so many people say someone
was robbed so much in a long time like I
remember there was um maybe like a
Pacquiao fight like 10 or 15 years ago
that I remember it was there was a lot
of back backlash on uh when I was living
in Vegas but it seems like the consensus
is that this guy was robbed
man any close fight they going to say
It's a Robbery yeah so it don't matter
like just because he's like a MMA person
and they they suspect Tyson F to just
wash him um if it's close of course they
going to say It's a Robbery so I don't I
a I ain't watched The First beginning
rounds to really tell you um but I all
I'm going say is I it just seemed like
they want that to be like the narrative
so well I mean look at the end of the
day like that that is something that
that a lot of people say about boxing is
that they feel like because it always
goes to scorecards that it there is room
for people to get robbed you know what
I'm saying like and from a Fan's
perspective you know what I mean I'm I'm
sure it could be frustrating to be like
yo there some bad judges there's some
bad judges out there right and then
there's rematches that people want to
have made and all this [__] right so I I
don't mean to cut you off before you ask
your question but I want to say um any
MMA fighters who uh feel as though that
they could jump in the boxing ring with
a box anybody close to my weight I would
love for y'all to jump in the ring with
me and uh try me out caror McGregor try
me out any of them I don't care which
one it is uh um Cody Crawley what's the
people that's like there's the guy who's
like the Maga dude who's fighting this
weekend uh Cody kington I yeah whatever
whatever whoever it is um that's close
to my way I would love for them to get a
r try me out well it's crazy cuz the
nana new dude like he like he held his
own like I was expecting him to get
smoked for sure and that's why I would
love to show like it ain't going to go
the same when I get in there I would
love to show like no MMA fighter could
get in the ring with me and even survive
have you had anybody approach you to do
anything like that cuz it seems like
that's kind of the the thing going right
now I heard it was somebody said that um
one of the guys said my name um what's
the guy he be going back and forth with
uh Devin too um I don't know his name I
don't know his name but uh like I said
any one of them dudes to step in the
ring I it feels like easy money for you
it is for sure but I just want to show
them like you can't jump in no boxing
ring right with me and it's going to go
that way I promise you I'm not going to
lie to that yeah I was a little
surprised to see that that fight went
the way it went cuz I ain't like it I
was like damn that's going to open up
the the the can of worms for everybody
to want to come in I felt like it it was
disrespectful um yo so this is the fight
that uh we're we're getting obviously uh
there's been been a lot of I mean
everybody's asked you about obviously
whenever you're going to fight Haney is
this going to happen after this fight is
there any sort of progression in those
talks cuz I think we keep hearing about
the negotiations following through maybe
he's not serious about fighting you what
what is is is that fight ever going to
get made I would love for the fight to
happen um [__] I y'all can clearly see
that I want the fight yeah like y'all
can clearly see I don't know why like
people try to spin the Nar NES and like
a lot of people good at social media so
they'll turn the narrative into
something else and 30 other people run
with that narrative but um truth be told
I love to fight like I I I fight anybody
yeah um I jumped in the ring with him
for a reason I didn't just jump in the
ring and do that for no other reason
besides okay let's get let's get the
fight started